what was going through your mind when
you were up there with track the judges
looked stunned were you stunned REE
surprised this has happened so many
times I kind of expected it to happen
the person that everyone thinks he's
gonna win never wins and the person
everyone thinks is not going usually
does so I wasn't stunned by a lot of the
former idols where they were voting for
me and that makes me feel really good
you know Kelly Clarkson Ruben Fantasia
all wanted me to win and that touches my
heart so I'm you know in my heart I'm
okay
I'm gonna ask how you're handling it
last night when you're getting these
tweets that Kelly Clarkson's no Carla
Porsche yeah I was really honored I've
touched a lot of people have inspired a
lot of people and so that's where I'm at
I mean I got the car me and Trent we're
talking last night we were eating
chick-fil-a and he was like Porsche do
you realize we got a car we broke down
while I was like yes so at this one we
literally didn't mind you know what
happened we both got a record deal we
both got a record deal right after you
came off stage they were like oh by the
way with by the way we have some good
news I'm like okay I'm thinking they're
talking about I got a gig or something
and they're like well you're signing
Motown and being seen and ninety records
anyways I'm like okay Wow